Violence, gore, and oh, so much nudity.
Plenty of ways to get an R-rating,
but who knew all it takes to get on the MPAA’s
bad side is a little magic and an F-bomb or two?
Written and directed by John Hughes, the 1985 teen
drama "The Breakfast Club" stars five members of
Hollywood's so-called "Brat Pack": Anthony Michael
Hall, Molly Ringwald, Emilio Estevez, Judd Nelson,
and Ally Sheedy. Set at a fictional high school,
the story revolves around a group of students
from different walks of life who seemingly
share nothing in common other than the fact
that they've all been assigned Saturday morning
detention. There we meet angry, malcontent Bender,
morose recluse Allison, cocky jock Andrew,
awkward and nerdy Brian, and snobby Claire.
Over the course of the film, the five
misfits muse over the struggles in their
vastly different lives, and they each come
to understand each other a little better.
It's a tender, heartfelt coming-of-age
story with few equals in its day. Sadly,
it earned itself an R-rating thanks to
its frank discussion of sex and drugs,
some crude language, plus a scene
where they get high together.
"Chicks cannot hold their
smoke. That's what it is."
But while edgy for the '80s, "The Breakfast
Club" isn't actually all that explicit,
using suggestive euphemisms more often
than not. And while some mild drug use
may have riled parents in 1985, it
hardly seems all that R-rated today.
Written and directed by Cameron Crowe, "Almost
Famous" is inspired by the filmmaker's own
unique life story, paralleling his days as a teen
journalist for Rolling Stone. The film follows
15-year-old William Miller, who worms his way
into the inner circle of an up-and-coming rock
group called Stillwater. Along with alluring
bohemian groupie Penny Lane, William joins the
band on tour, going on a journey of self-discovery
as he learns about life, love, and friendship.
A touching story of a young man
looking to find his own path,
"Almost Famous" got its R-rating thanks to
some of the usual swear words and drug use.
"I'm on drugs!"
What might have crossed the line, however, was
a single partial nude scene where Penny Lane is
briefly seen dancing with her shirt hanging
open. But take that out and what you're left
with is a rather subdued story — where most of
the sex and drugs are only implied — and with
none of the raucous antics you might expect from
a more wild and crazy rock n' roll biopic. Given
its poignant story of youthful rebellion
and the moral lessons it peddles, it seems
almost a crime that its target audience
was kept out of theaters by its R-rating.
An absolutely iconic buddy comedy, "Blazing
Saddles" is a 1974 Western classic starring
Gene Wilder and Cleavon Little as a pair of
mismatched partners in the Old West. Written
and directed by Mel Brooks, it puts Little into
the role of Bart, a black laborer who becomes the
new sheriff of Rock Ridge. But Bart is only given
the job because the corrupt governor hopes it will
prompt the townsfolk to flee, allowing a railroad
to dismantle the town. When Bart gets wind of the
plan, though, he recruits local outlaw Jim to
help him stop the governor's dastardly scheme.
A major hit, "Blazing Saddles" pulled in
a whopping $119 million at the box office
thanks to the chemistry of its star pair and
a sidesplitting script from Brooks. A wildly
successful movie among critics too, it's been
hailed as one of the best comedies of all time
and even earned itself four stars from Roger
Ebert. But despite its success, we're forced to
wonder how much more popular it might have been
had it not received an R-rating, mostly because
it doesn't deserve it. Sure, in 1974, some of the
more vulgar jokes may have offended uptight types.
*fart sounds*
Looking back, though, it wouldn't earn that
rating today, as much of what crossed the
line at the time is more veiled humor
and innuendo than anything explicit.
When it comes to action movies, it
can be fairly easy for a tame flick
to just barely cross the line and earn an
R-rating. In the case of "Constantine," we
don't suspect it was the violence, blood,
or death that got it a stricter label,
but its overall tone and dark themes. The film
centers on the eponymous John Constantine,
who has been sent to Hell, but is back on Earth
where he fights for righteousness — hunting
demons and fallen angels — in an effort to
stave off his soul's delivery to Lucifer.
The movie has some fantasy violence, and there
are a few grim moments, but the overall tone is
often rather tongue-in-cheek. Nevertheless,
it's the demonic nature of the story that is
most likely to blame for its harsh rating.
The MPAA cautioned viewers that the film
contained "violence and demonic images,"
but the violence hardly seems any worse
than your standard PG-13 blockbuster. And while
hellish visuals may be cause for concern for
more devout religious folk, it might not
even register as harsh for anyone else.
It's certainly not a surprise to learn that
one of the most popular horror movies of the
2010s is rated R. But when you actually sit down
to watch "The Conjuring," the 2013 ghost story
by director James Wan, you might be surprised
to find it's really not that shocking at all.
The film tells the story of a pair of supernatural
experts played by Patrick Wilson and Vera Farmiga,
who are brought in to investigate a potential
haunting at a remote farmhouse. Given the
R-rating by the MPAA for "terror," it seems it
was the overall spooky vibe that rankled the
labeling agency rather than any explicit
bloodshed or even disturbing visuals.
*clap clap*
Because frankly, the film isn't really
all that violent. And according to Wan,
that was by design, as he'd held out hope of
the film making it out with a PG-13 rating,
in an effort to attract a wider audience.
But as the film's producer Walter Hamada told
fans during an appearance at WonderCon not long
before its release, the MPAA had told him they
were stuck with a stricter rating. He explained:
"It's just so scary. [There
are] no specific scenes or
tone you could take out to get it PG-13."
Eighth Grade
It seems like critically acclaimed coming-of-age
stories can often fall victim to the R-rating
despite it not being warranted. That
might be because being earnest and true
to life sometimes means showing young, often
underage characters acting crudely and vulgar,
or engaging in taboo activities like sex
and drugs as they navigate their way into
adulthood. Such is the case with comedian
Bo Burnham's full-length directorial debut,
"Eighth Grade," which introduces us to Kayla Day,
an ordinary middle schooler struggling with stress
at school and at home as she prepares
to graduate the titular year of school.
Aimed at an audience of teens,
the film is a tender and heartbreaking
look at adolescence and was praised by
critics and young audiences for its realistic
depiction of growing up in modern America.
"What was in there?"
"Just sort of my hopes and dreams."
Unfortunately, thanks to some pervasive
profanity and a couple of suggestive moments,
the film garnered an R-rating, preventing
kids who might relate to it from seeing
it in the theater on their own. Of course, this
effectively cut them out from seeing it at all,
as we're not sure any 15-year-old wants to
be going to the movies with their parents.
A watershed movie from 1999 that mixed sci-fi and
action, "The Matrix" revolutionized both genres,
with groundbreaking special effects and
a mind-bending, immersive story that had
audiences questioning reality itself. Full of
dazzling visuals that included the innovative
"bullet time" effect, the film's mix of rapid-fire
martial arts moves and break-neck, guns-blazing
shootouts had the audience's jaws on the floor.
The film follows Neo, a young hacker played
by Keanu Reeves, who is recruited by Laurence
Fishburne's enigmatic Morpheus, and learns that
the world as he knows it is merely a constructed
reality, and he is the key to saving mankind.
Exploring deeply philosophical issues like fate
vs. free will and the nature of identity, "The
Matrix" captivated movie-goers like few films ever
had. But with plenty of violence, including loads
of hot lead sprayed like water, and shoot-outs
that left dozens dead, this is one film that
might not come as a surprise to learn was rated R.
But watch the film with a more discerning eye and
you might start to rethink everything you thought
you knew about it. Because on closer inspection,
you'll notice that most of the violence is
almost entirely bloodless — and the victims all
simulations. With a few minor tweaks, "The Matrix"
could probably have snagged a PG-13 rating.
Spun out of a series of impromptu performances
from "Saturday Night Live," the 1980 film "The
Blues Brothers," is directed by John
Landis and stars John Belushi and Dan
Aykroyd. They put on fedoras, suits, and shades to
become Jake and Elwood Blues, a pair of musically
inclined ex-cons who find themselves clashing with
police, a gang of Neo-Nazis, a rival music group,
and a crazed killer, all while trying to save a
Catholic orphanage from going under. To complete
their "mission from God," the Blues Brothers
need to raise $5,000, which they plan to do
by putting on a musical showcase, and must
recruit other musicians to make it happen.
With very little violence, "The Blues
Brothers" is much more like a classic
'80s caper and buddy comedy than any kind
of violent action movie you might expect
would warrant an R-rating. But indeed,
that's just the rating it received,
owed almost entirely to its
generous use of swear words.
"Christ Jake, take it easy man."
"That word."
"Ow, s---!"
"Jesus Christ!"
"S---!"
"God dammit!"
And while that did necessitate the harder
rating, the movie was a big hit anyway,
and the censors seemed to get it right the
next time around because the belated sequel,
"Blues Brothers 2000," was
handed a PG-13 rating in 1998.
"The Craft" was a pioneer in the
sub-genre of supernatural teen dramas,
led by a foursome of troubled young women imbued
with otherworldly powers. Starring Robin Tunney,
Fairuza Balk, Neve Campbell, and Rachel True,
the film's mix of coming-of-age story and dark,
supernatural horror may have been a poor choice
if they were looking for a PG-13 rating. Combining
those two elements may have been what doomed
it to the hard R-rating, much to the chagrin
of younger teens — although the film did
still manage to be a hit at the box office.
Admittedly, there are a few moments in "The Craft"
that could have rightfully warranted its label:
There are a couple deaths that border on
graphic, as well as a scene where one of
the young women is the target of a failed
sexual assault. But it's not that far
from most of the PG-13 thrillers you'd see
today. Sure, there's some crude language,
and vague discussion of sex and drugs, though
almost none of it is shown on screen. What
might have pushed it over the edge, however,
is a wrist-slashing scene that includes plenty
of blood. It's a disturbing sequence that
some audiences might understandably want
to be cautioned against. But considering that
the 2020 sequel, "The Craft: Legacy," wasn't
much different and garnered a PG-13, it makes one
wonder if the original's R was a bit of a reach.
In what might be one of the most egregious
examples of a movie being given a harder
rating than it deserved, the 2010 drama "The
King's Speech" was slapped with an R for one
simple reason: too many "F" words. But
the use of profanity wasn't gratuitous
or unmotivated and was actually a key
component in the story of the life of
England's King George VI, who suffered
from a debilitating speech impediment.
Set in the 1930s, "The King's Speech" is the
remarkable true story of the real Prince Albert,
who is faced with the terrifying prospect of
giving a national speech on his ascension to
King after his brother abdicates the throne.
The crux of the story centers on his treatment
for a stammer with the help of speech therapist,
Lionel Logue. Logue is able to help Albert with
some unorthodox methods and eventually makes
the realization that swearing can help abate
Albert's stutter. And it's a now-famous
scene that led to the film's R-rating,
as Albert lets loose a torrent of comical
obscenities in a session with Logue.
"Bugger bugger buggity buggity
buggity f--- f--- ass!"
"Yes!"
Unfortunately, because of its importance to
the story, the swearing is not a superficial
element that can be easily excised to
get a lighter rating. But no matter,
because the film went on to win critical
acclaim en route to capturing the Academy
Award for best picture, and earning its
lead, Colin Firth, an Oscar for best actor.